in California's Central Valley almost
everywhere you look you'll see one of
these wells the drought has caused a
drilling boom as farmers go digging for
water my older wells for the amount of
land I have just couldn't keep up and so
in order for me to irrigate had to drill
two new wells dairy farmer will de
Groote had no choice but to dig two new
wells to get water for his cattle and
land this year I've had to leave about
300 acres fallow because I couldn't grow
any feet because I didn't have any water
here in Tulare County well drilling has
tripled Steve Arthur is drilling to
gluts new wells he runs one of many
drilling companies in the region is
working round the clock to keep up with
booming demand business is up about 50%
I get about three to four hours a night
sleep if I'm lucky
well the backlog gets longer because of
these wells get harder and deeper
it's just crazy out there right now
there was a long waiting list for the
well I got on the list September of last
year and so it's taken a full year this
well we'll reach a total depth of 1,200
feet when it's finished we got a pretty
good idea in this area where the water
is but some of the areas that if we're
going deeper will actually drill a pilot
hole first then we'll running electric
logs and that basically gives us a map
of the ground off of that we can get a
general idea how much water to expect
the crude is hoping to get a thousand
gallons a minute from this well and that
water doesn't come cheap Arthur charges
as much as a quarter of a million
dollars for a well and for a deep well
the cost can run up to $750,000 it's not
easy I'm gonna have to borrow from the
bank to pay for this everybody thinks
well drillers are making millions and
millions of dollars we're making a
little bit of money but then we also
have a lot more cost a new rig alone is
about a million two million three
if this dry spell continues there is a
risk that the groundwater reserves will
be depleted if this drought continues
what's a scary scary thought because I
also have two wells here on my dairy
that supply drinking water for my cows
and if they go dry I don't know that's
just a scary thought I don't want to go
there
you